[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud loud proud proud and do not
give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
right of other people is not Liberty you
[__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
them the house
gqp where stupidity meets
Edition more p strengths again and the
wiener of the house mikro Johnson
confirms this morning that he is the
leader of the deep State that's right
that's right conservatives that's right
right-wingers micro Johnson the wiener
of the house is the leader of the deep
State as he censors the January 6
footage can't make this [__]
up you can't Washington Post also I
guess being told that Liz Cheney is
considering a third-party run hey how do
you feel about me hating Liz Cheney
now that's so dumb of course she's
thinking about a third-party run that's
why she was so lukewarm on voting for
Joe
Biden maybe Tony's on to
something maybe the media shouldn't give
her a platform maybe they shouldn't
unless unless she wants to [__]
apologize
she's ready to [__] apologize to the
American people for delivering us Donald
Trump then then then maybe maybe just
maybe I'll listen to Liz Cheney being a
hero for democracy otherwise you can
[__] right off all the way all the way
off [__] you yes that's right washing
post saying Liz Cheney is floating the
idea of a thirdparty
run this is what I
what I warn you this [__] about don't
[__] listen to [__] that makes you
feel good listen to the [__] truth
and know the truth even if it doesn't
[__] you know package up in a nice
little tight bow and look like sunshine
and
rainbows doesn't [__] matter it
doesn't
matter you will undermine democracy if
you do not pay pay the [__]
attention so but if you're here then
you're paying attention whether you like
it or
not you're paying
attention we will March forward as the
pro-democracy
Coalition and we will win the next
election for
democracy that's how it
works we we've seen it play out in the
last several elections and the last
several special elections for crying out
loud in an off
year Ohio Virginia Kentucky and almost
the Mississippi
Governor goes to
Democrats in the way of of protecting
women's rights to Health
Care all the
while Jim comr pile I love that new
nickname comr
pile I make it all one
word because I think it's one word comr
pile that's a nickname it's not his name
it's a nickname comr pile and comr
pile has Hunter derangement syndrome I
don't know if you heard the evidence
yesterday but apparently Hunter Biden
made Chinese payments to Joe Biden
monthly
payments that's right Hunter Biden made
Chinese monthly payments to Joe Biden
and their bribery payments apparently is
what comr pile thinks now the problem is
is that this is repayment for a down
payment on a pickup truck like they
literally took a picture of Hunter Biden
with Joe Biden buying the [__] pickup
truck
so stupid this is the dumbest [__] I
have ever and really honestly keep
jumping on the rakes friends keep doing
it keep
going when the American people find out
that the Republicans are going to
impeach Joe Biden for loaning Hunter
Biden
$4,100 and hunterbiden paying it
back over like three or four months and
that's why we're going to impeach Joe
Biden they're going to [__] laugh at
them I don't know I don't know if you
have parents or other people have
parents but normally normally parents
will do just about anything to help
their children even loan them a couple
thousand bucks and wait a while to get
it paid back with no interest like most
of the time parents will loan money to
their
kids sometimes not even expected to be
paid back
sometimes it gives pay back sometimes it
don't it
doesn't it happens it's like a societal
thing and the Republicans think that
this is the overall arcing narrative
because if you remember Let me refresh
you if you if you if you haven't been
paying attention to the stupidity coming
out of the Sedition caucus of the
house first it was $4
million that was the first am we were
told that Joe Biden is corrupt four
million bucks and it wasn't Biden it was
the Biden family right because they
couldn't pend it on Joe Biden because
there's no $4 million payment to Joe
Biden it doesn't exist then it was 10
million I'm not kidding you they went to
10 then to 20 then to $40 million okay
last weekend Donald Trump stood on stage
and said it was F 5
billion 5 billion it quickly went from 4
million to 5 billion to
$200,000 that James Biden Joe Biden's
brother paid him back with no interest
on a no interest
loan no interest okay you follow me no
interest no monetary
benefit okay bear with me here if you
give someone a $100 right and you're
like okay I want you to launder this
$100 so what you're going to do is
you're going to give me a $100 back
you're the worst [__] money launderer
in the goddamn world the worst the
world's [__] worst money launderer
you're not even in the same universe as
the worst moneya launderer to be quite
honest
okay so it went from from 4 million to 5
billion to 200,000 really quickly and
then yesterday it went to 4
$4,100 folks
$4,100 is what their
claiming is going to be an impeachable
offense I'm not [__] I wouldn't [__] you
you're my favorite
turd I'm not [__] you this is this
is this is how it how it's
degraded now the good news is is that
Republicans are doubling down on this
idea
good [__] them I hope we get to where
eventually Joe Biden let Hunter Biden
buy him an ice cream cone oh my f
impeach that [__] Hunter Biden
paid for his lunch are you [__]
kidding me this is outrageous outrageous
wait are you saying are you telling me
that Joe Biden is acquainted with Hunter
Biden oh my God they talk almost twice a
week folks this is outrageous I cannot
believe that Joe Biden is communicating
with Hunter Biden a couple times a week
this is ridiculous impeach him that's
where we're headed like literally that
that is where we are
going when they're when they're gonna
talk about
impeaching Joe Biden because he gave
$4,100 for a down payment on a truck and
his son paid him back with no interest
again the worst moneya laundering scheme
in the world now I'm going to show you a
clip where comr pile's like yeah yeah
but it was it was money from China no
it's money from Hunter Biden's business
that's how he makes money like it's his
income you [__]
bonehead Hunter Biden is a business
owner folks he's a business he doesn't
work a ninet to-5 he doesn't have a
W2 okay that's not how Hunter Biden
makes money it's not you may not like it
he may be an elite if you see it that
way that he makes money
Consulting with with different agencies
and different businesses in different
countries but that's how he makes money
that's his living and when he makes
money for a living he he pays money to
himself like you know out of his
business if you had like my business LLC
and you made money with that and then
and and then you paid yourself money so
you could pay like your truck payment
your light bill your house payment it's
all so
stupid it's all so really [__]
stupid the thing is is that Hunter
Biden's truck is probably probably a
business expense he probably use it to
deduct it from his income because he
uses it like to drive around and do his
Consulting
work it's it's really [__] dumb and
all these people know this [__] James
comr comr pile knows I bet that
[__] uses truck payments to
deduct in his businesses with him and
his [__] scummy ass family where he
received a $200,000 exchange with his
brother and I hope that Jared moscowitz
finds where James comr
has has released his public tax returns
and his financial statements where he
has taken a deduction for a [__]
vehicle and paid payments to take that
[__] deduction this is so dumb it's
dumb as
[__] but this is the narrative that
they're GNA go with 4,100
bucks and Hunter Biden paying it back
with no interest none the worst [__]
money launderers in the the goddamn
world if that's what they're doing
because that's what James comr is
claiming that Hunter Biden makes money
Consulting businesses in China he gets
paid for doing that work and then he
pays back a loan that his dad gave him
with no interest he's claiming that Joe
Biden received Chinese
funds that's what he that's what they're
saying that's literally their case that
they're trying to make out in the open
and you're wondering why now Hunter
Biden wants to [__] testify in
public it's the easiest slam dunk
ever ever and really honestly they're
only making a case for the American
people about how corrupt Joe Biden
isn't that's all they're doing not to
mention that these payments where when
when Jo Joe Biden went to the dealership
with him there's a [__] picture of it
I put it on my thumbnail that's how
embarrassed I am that's how scared I am
of the house gop's investigation into
Joe Biden is my liberal libertar dumbass
put the picture on the
thumbnail you people are you you people
who believe the [__] Republicans you
believe these lies and you have Hunter
derangement
syndrome you people are [__] dumb as
dog
[__] I mean I get I get all this [__]
and comments how I have Trump
derangement syndrome and all this [__]
listen out of all the Liberals in the
media out there I had probably have the
least amount of trump derangement
syndrome because I'm the only one that's
saying we're gonna whoop his [__] ass
this guy's gonna be [__] easy to beat
I was listening to MSNBC this morning
because I'm trying to see if they're
changing their tune and they are they
are changing their tune folks they're
just not quite there yet they're still
terrified terrified that Trump's going
to going to be the nominee it's really
stupid [__] and I know most people out
there don't want him to be the nominee
folks he's the easiest [__] to
beat easiest [__] to beat I
don't know if you I don't know if you
noticed I don't know if you've been
listening to his blathering he is not
popular and he's only be gonna become
more unpopular as he keeps puking up his
[__] fascist
garbage and it's up to us to make him
unpopular it's up to us to [__] beat him
we have to do our jobs but I'm highly
confident that the American people are
going to do their jobs and put this
[__] in the trash bin of History
I'm very
confident and the reason why is because
I believe that a national narrative that
is set in a certain way will absolutely
[__] tear apart the GOP and their
stupid [__] lies it's so
easy
how the [__] can't we see that these
people are ninka poop Nazis and they're
the easiest Nazis in history to
beat the
easiest and I know I know I know a lot
of people want the fear
porn right they want they want they want
the fear mongering and [__] and listen
you should you should at some degree
recognize the threat right I'm not
saying don't recognize the threat when
you see it right I've never said that
definitely identify the threat look at
the threat make sure everyone knows the
threat and then everyone act
accordingly that's all I'm
saying that's all I'm saying and I
understand that you know people want him
locked up I want him locked up for his
crimes they want him 14th which is
[__] bogus and stupid you're not
going to get him 14th it ain't going to
happen it's dumb
it's like saying Liz Cheney is some kind
of [__] hero when she ain't she ain't
no [__]
hero I'm gonna show you a clip where she
admits she admits without admitting that
she is part of the
problem she knows she did this to us
that's right Liz Cheney did this to us I
don't give a [__] how you want to talk
about it how much you want to spend her
dumbass book and what she knows and what
she doesn't know and what she says now
Liz Cheney did this to
us she's responsible for this the
situation that she's fighting against
now she did it so yeah she should be the
[__] first one out there fighting
against it but the first thing she
should do is at least acknowledge she
[__] caused this problem and a
apologize for that [__] to the American
people all the [__] she says now
will just fall on deaf ears if she does
not and she hasn't she hasn't I don't
give a [__] you come at me in my Twitter
comments and talk about how oh well
she's a fighter for democracy now and
all that
[__] all that nonsense will fall on
deaf ears
folks all of
it
because they'll just pin her up as some
kind of libtard democrat and she ain't
that she's a goddamn
Nazi she's one of them [__] she
just ain't invited to their parties no
more she's one of them she's [__] one
of them don't [__] forget that [__]
and when this ticks on in the next three
or four months and Donald Trump
obviously takes the nomination for the
Republican party when he wins the C uses
when he wins New Hampshire he slam dunks
Nikki Haley in South Carolina it's done
done done done that's it there's there's
no recovering the nomination for the
Republican party after that you
understand that right I've known this
from the beginning I knew this when
Nikki Haley was [__] somehow acted
like she was gonna run for
president and he absolutely destroyed
her everyone keeps talking about Nikki
Haley like she's going to be the nominee
what the [__] are you talking about if
she can't win in her home state of South
Carolina she's done that's
it there's no managing that campaign
after that if Ronda santis loses in Iowa
he's [__]
finished this is how it works
[__] now the media the
mainstream media has come around to this
idea right they're really on board with
me now they finally come around to the
fact that I've been saying for damn near
a year a year I've been saying that
Donald Trump is gonna be the
nominee they're finally coming around to
it and they're finally getting a sense
of oh my God he's gonna be the nominee
because now they're doing pieces in the
Atlantic uh postulating what a trump
presidency will be like and David fr
comes out there on TV because he was
help wrote this this postulation in the
Atlantic and they keep they keep
yammering on with fear
porn with fear
porn about what is to come which I'm not
saying that's a bad thing it's not a bad
thing but I know what they're trying to
do what the media is trying to do is
scare people into nominating someone
else that's what what they're trying to
do I know
it they're trying to get ahead of trump
in the nomination process and it ain't
going to
happen the cult is not going to leave
him they're not what the what the [__]
what the [__] clue more clues do you
need what more evidence do you need
folks they're
lost the Republican party is dead
and to treat it like we can revive it
somehow through Liz Cheney or nominating
Nikki Haley or some dumb [__] like that
is just the most ridiculous thing I've
ever heard in my
life they're
dead and the longer we drag around this
dead body around the country acting like
we can revive this
thing the longer we're going to have
this stupid [__]
problem we're a two-party country and we
only have one party because the other
party is dead and that's really the the
[__] Growing Pains that we're going
through
here that's the heartache that this
country is suffering
from until we actually
form and they form another party the
people who want to be more conservative
than liberal which is your right in this
country you get to have stupid [__]
beliefs in this country you get to have
stupid [__] ideas you get to believe
in stupid [__] policy that doesn't
work you get to do that in this country
that's your
Liberty and you get to form political
parties
that use stupid [__] policy as their
platform you do it's a thing it's called
Liberty Liberty allows for
stupidity unfortunately that's just how
that some sometimes the consequences of
all of us living
free it just is and until you [__]
come to that moment and realize
that you're not going to get to the
point and the point is is that they're
going to nominate Donald Trump they're
authoritarians they're white Christian
nationalist they're Nazis they want a
Hitler
I don't know how many more times it has
to be said and more clear that it has to
be said they're [__] Nazis okay
they're [__] Nazis they're fascist
they want fascism they want a fascist
dictator this is what fascism breeds
that's what they want and they want it
in their fascism in the form of white
Christian
nationalism that's what they want it's
obvious it couldn't be any more
clearer I'm going to show you videos
today to make it even more clear and it
still won't sink into the
media that you're not you don't get to
tell people who to nominate you don't
get to tell people that Joe Biden isn't
the guy you don't get to tell MAA that
Trump isn't their cult
leader
that is the problem that the media
has the Free Press wants to
be the setter of narratives and they're
not anymore they lost that power they
lost that power with
technology I mean [__] there's thousands
and thousands of people that come watch
this show every day every [__] day
and who the [__] am I who the [__] is
this guy
just some dude with a [__] webcam and
a mouse
huh it's all about ideas folks it's all
about
narrative and they're mad that they've
lost the grip on
narrative we the people get to set the
narrative we do we can we can as a
coalition and it doesn't have to be some
kind of [__] some kind of official
branded
Coalition it
doesn't it doesn't have to be you don't
have to be affiliated with this group or
that group or I gotta be with them or I
got to be on their board or I got I
gotta be with Lincoln project I got to
make sure I'm with mest touch I got to
make sure I'm with this group and that
group I gotta make sure I love this
person I love that I gotta make sure I
believe everything that Glenn number two
says it does not have to be
defined
the pro-democracy Coalition can be built
on one idea and one idea only democracy
over autocracy that's
it we can choose democracy it ain't
perfect democracy is not that's the
design that's the beauty of
democracy that's the beauty of it is it
changes it
progresses it's a living breathing
[__] thing
because we're living breathing
things and the democracy is us it's
[__] us it's the people it says it we
the people those [__] those
[__] that were slave owners
that only wanted rich white men to have
property even they understood
it even they understood and maybe maybe
maybe just maybe they saw this coming
highly
unlikely but maybe they saw this coming
that's why they use those
words and that's why they marked it down
that
way so it's up to you it's up to you
it's not up to the [__] media it's
not up to Fox News it's not up to
[__] to to
Maga MAA ain't no [__] big tank
Coalition folks if you haven't noticed
they [__] sneeze one thing against
Trump and they're out you're out you're
out of manga you're not [__] you're
not Nazi
enough so it's left up to us and we're
the bigger Coalition
anyways even without the all the [__]
the blue and on left holy [__] these
people are wild they believe wild crazy
[__] these [__] delusional leftist
holy [__] oh man I mean at one point I
thought the Bernie Bros were [__]
just absolutely ridiculous the people
who went and gobbled up tyt's lies for
their grift woo I thought those people
were out there out to lunch but these
[__] blueing on people that believe
anything that they're said holy [__]
it's wild
stuff wild stuff but we're the biggest
Coalition don't forget that don't forget
that and there's only one one thing that
pins us all together only one and that's
Dem Ry Liberty and freedom democracy
over
autocracy that's the key that's the key
and the key is to come here every single
[__] weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours no matter how good my
voice is or isn't it's getting better
though I think I think it's getting
better can you hear it can you hear it I
want to thank everyone who's purchased
tattoo merch that's right the new
tattoo collection is out you go to Tony
michaels.com this machine kills Fascism
and fascist that's right I'm going to
get this tattooed on my arm it's going
to go right here in January so go get
your tattoo merch that'll help uh pay
for the tattoo if you uh also want to
help with the tattoo go go go put money
in the tip jar buy me some shots that
help as well I also want to pimp the
book club that's right I'm going to pimp
the book club the library of democracy
is sponsoring the book club on our [__]
them fam Discord they're going to be
reading win every argument win every
argument by Min Assan just go to Theon
michaels.com scroll down to the
memberships tab you will find the book
club there you do have to join the
Discord now you don't have to
participate in all the other stuff the
discord's fun though if you if you want
to get in there and talk to people
likeminded [__] them fam and you'll grab
a few memes that you can share around on
social media but also you can join in on
the book club they'll be reading win
every argument my mini Assan next
they're also doing Rachel mad's audio
book in there as well right now so go
join the book club today go join the
book club today don't go anywhere either
because you know we're going to be right
back with more [__] and more more
[__] them right after this stick around
we'll be right back don't go anywhere
we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds this
is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
part and blanket I've got you covered
paron blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup part
and blanket will protect you too Hardon
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
100% made in the USA don't delay and get
your pardon blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the
show how are you [__] this
morning how is you on this Tuesday
morning are you getting ready for
Christmas and the holiday season are you
already in that
[Music]
mood what do you
think uh Texas Paul I think's going to
be a little late today he said he was
going to make it though so I think we're
gonna have Texas Paul with us today so
just just bear with us I'm gonna go
through this uh Michael Johnson being
the head of the deep State first though
that's where we're going to go first um
as we go through
this someone someone's pointing out that
Boston Brian is in the chat he said U
hello you handsome bastard of course I'm
a handsome bastard I'm the best looking
some [__] on the internet that's right
I'll say it I you know what am I
supposed to do what am I supposed to do
ignore this
beauty that that is projected through
the interwebs this I I'm I'm going to
tell you though it could just be a
beauty filter it could be I'm an ugly
some [__] behind this you know what I
mean and I just turn on a beauty filler
I don't know maybe but thanks Boston
Bryan you're handsome
too oh boy someone that'll gross you out
though is this guy here's this guy here
[__] micro micro Johnson the wiener
of the
house
now you didn't probably know this but
Micro Johnson here is the leader of the
deep
State he admitted it this morning he
admitt it this morning Texas Paul he
admitted it this morning that he's the
leader of the deep state where the hell
you been I thought you were gonna be
late you're not late how man I hurried
home I wanted to be here brother I love
doing this show with you my
man I
drove drove home like it was
NASCAR
I got no audio from you
brother did you get a new microphone or
something I did I did I got a got an sm7
DB oh I see what is it SM sure sm7
DB okay it's the new they it's the they
put a cloud lifter inside the sn7
sm7b and uh change the switches on the
back and same mic it's a sm7b is what it
is I see I see all right well they sent
me sounds like a fancy
one Speaking of uh trying to be fancy
this guy here now Texas Paul I don't
know if you knew this or not
but Micro Johnson is the leader of the
deep State and he lets it Loose here in
this uh this clip listen to what he says
well look the impeachment inquiry is
necessary because um as you know our our
Committees of jurisdiction oversight
Judiciary Ways and Means chairman uh
comr and Jordan and Smith have done an
extraordinary job following the facts on
this remember remember it's the article
one of the Constitution gives the house
the impeachment Authority and I've said
at this ah it's the wrong [__] clip
God damn it hang on hang on that's the
wrong clip that's the wrong clip that
ain't the Deep State clip let me find
the Deep State clip here yeah yeah yeah
yeah you make fun of me all
you [__] rat bastard in the
background don't feel bad I ran a three
minute clip the other day and uh uh was
doing commentary on it this that the
other and forgot to hit screen share
forgot to the screen share yeah I'm
there talking about it and everybody in
the comments is like are we missing
something are you see I mean I went
through the whole damn clip man finally
Mrs Texas Paul
pull prize open my office door uh there
ain't nothing on the screen
man well you know I actually um someone
someone uh queued me in on another thing
that happened on your show the other day
they sent me they sent me yeah they sent
me a clip I might play it today I don't
know why you're here you can you can um
you can answer for your new microphone
and uh how much it picks up in the room
um I don't know we might we might go
there we might not I don't know we'll
we'll we'll see we'll see here's the
actual clip that I wanted to show you uh
of of micro Johnson the wiener of the
house admitting admitting that he is the
Deep State and he's referring to him
releasing the January six tapes listen
to this trust the American people to
draw their own conclusions we should not
they should not be dictated by some
narrative and accept that as fact so
they can review the tapes themselves
we're going through a methodical process
of releasing them is as quickly as we
can as you know we have to blur some of
the faces of persons who uh participated
in in the in the events of that day
because what what what wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait a second Texas
Paul I have been
told I have been told that it is the FBI
and it is the Deep State and it was
antifa and black lives matter that we
are trying to make sure that we know the
truth about January 6 why in the [__]
are they going to take time to blur out
faces on the January 6 footage could it
be could it be that these internet slle
that these sedition Hunters are finding
these January 6 insurrectionists these
Trump
supporters uh when micro Johnson is
releasing these tapes and Reporting it
to the FBI and then the FBI is going
arrest them could it be that or could it
be that you know they have to censor
they have to censor the January 6 tape
so we don't see the Trump supporters is
that what he just said I think that's
what the Deep State Overlord just
said yeah I mean it it's hilarious all
the mental gymnastics that are going on
in this because you got people on on in
you know in [__] that are just losing
their minds because they're saying oh
well he's no better than Kevin McCarthy
because he promised to release a takes
and only released 1% and then you've got
people on our side of the aisle that are
like yeah I'm so glad he's released in
those tapes because three more people
got found by the FBI that were on those
tapes you know and here he is saying oh
we're now we're going to blur their
faces because he doesn't want to be the
guy that's sending his own people to
jail because his side is already getting
pissed at him I mean it's it's it's
hilarious watching what's happening they
are losing their damn Minds over there
on that side of the aisle with Mike
Johnson they I mean they're he's they're
going after him from being a big spender
they're going after him over the January
6 tapes this guy is screwed man because
he's got to make a deal on
Ukraine and that will be that that'll be
the one that will make their heads
explode that'll send them over the top I
promise you well chrisy here on YouTube
says maybe Tony is AI maybe me as AI or
or
maybe or maybe micro Johnson is using AI
because this this is the thing is I
would see that that the uh the house the
the people who are releasing this
tape this footage are actually probably
using AI to find these Trump supporters
and they're using it to blur these faces
um
now I just think it's [__]
hilarious that Tucker Carlson maror
Taylor green um Kevin McCarthy uh Donald
Trump now now mikro Johnson they yell
and scream about about releasing these
tapes because it'll tell us the truth
and so much of the truth that now they
want to censor the truth micro Johnson
does let's finish up this clip and see
what he says we don't want them to be
retaliated against and uh and and and to
be charged by the doj and oh we don't
want them to be brought to Justice Texas
poll Oh I thought it was just we didn't
want we didn't want we don't want the
truth we don't want the actual truth we
want we want the truth that we feel good
about that's what they want that's what
MAA wants that's what micro Johnson
wants he doesn't want he doesn't want
Trump supporters to be charged for
January 6 and to have other uh you know
concerns and problems so uh that's a
slow process to get it done we're
working steadily on it we've hired
additional Personnel to do that and uh
all of those tapes ultimately at the end
will be out so everybody can see them
and draw their own conclusions no they
won't be out they won't be out we won't
be able to see them we won't be able to
draw our own conclusions because the
Deep state is is is using their power to
censor these January 6 tapes Paul you
know the Wright always yells and scream
about the Deep state but it is them that
is the Deep state it is them that don't
want the truth it is them that don't
want that do not want the population to
know the full truth because the truth
shall set us free and know that maanga
are domestic terrorists and it is the
Republican party that are the domestic
terrorist and they're trying to
undermine and and take away our
democracy that's what it is now I
actually commented Gabe Sanchez post
this he says wow now Mike Johnson is
advocating for censorship classic I
actually tagged the Sedition Hunters I
said they should file suit and the
Sedition Hunters should file suit they
should file suit uh if he's going to
release this tape there is not a chance
in the world that micro Johnson should
censor this tape if you're going to
release the tape for the truth for the
American people to know then release the
[__] tape if you don't want the
American people to know this [__] then
don't release it you [__] make up
your mind you choose you make up your
mind now there was a tape Texas Paul in
Arlington Virginia that caught the
Internet by storm yesterday and I can I
throw one more thing out there yeah go
ahead go ahead you know if there's
nothing on the tapes why the hell do you
got to censor why why do you if there's
nothing on the tapes to show if this is
just you know what they keep portraying
it why do you have to censor
it why do you have to blur faces I mean
because they don't want you to know they
don't want people to know the
truth they just
don't but you get my point though Tony I
mean if if your narrative is that
there's nothing there that that this is
just the doj picking on people this is
just you know if that is your
argument why do you have to censor I
mean it ain't the do people micro
Johnson is releasing the tape what what
the [__] I mean here's the
thing and you know uh some people will
say well the Department of Justice has
access to this tape but the problem is
is there's 40,000 hours of this tape and
there's only so many FBI agents that
they can put on this but the Sedition
Hunters with the power of the SLO of the
internet and the power of crowdsourcing
to find people on social media it that
that is where they found a lot of these
people I don't I don't know if people
know this but the FBI and do
they actually put out wanted posters all
the time you go to the post office and
they just got books and books and books
of people who are wanted by the FBI and
doj and then then they have the most
wanted and they just have wanted posters
and there is a shitload a shitload of
these insurrections that are still
wanted by the FBI and doj and they're
and they're they're at your local post
office like you can go look and you can
go to the FBI's website too if you don't
if you don't like the old way if you
want to use technology the new way you
can go look at all all these
insurrections that they haven't found
yet that they are looking for um but the
Sedition hunters and the internet and
the internet's loose did a lot of this
work for the FBI because the FBI wants
people to help them get tips to make
sure people are brought to Justice
they've done it for a long time it's
it's a it's it's a long tradition of
Justice in our country that Americans
when they see something they say
something but that's what the
Republicans are fighting against it's
not even that they don't want the doj
and FBI they don't want citizens to know
the truth so that we can when we see
something we say
something well brother I I totally get
that point and I totally agree with what
you're saying there 100% I I get it I
just the hypocrisy of it to sit there on
one on one end and say oh it's not us
it's we it wasn't us it was antifa it
was the FBI and and they were just
peaceful
God-fearing American loving people up
there just just being as peaceful as can
be then why the [__] do you have to
censor it if it if your narrative is
true you shouldn't have to blur a damn
thing not a damn thing
period Well I want to show you another
tape and I'm getting curious about this
speaking of conspiracy theories maybe
I'll put my tenf foil hat on here but um
here's the deal is that there was an
internet video yesterday from Arlington
Virginia that went wild on the internet
here it is let me show you this this is
a house that
exploded um
yesterday and it was in Arlington
Virginia now if anyone isn't aware
Arlington Virginia is only a pipe bombs
walk away from Washington DC um and I
say a pipe bomb's walk because I kind of
want to know if anyone's seen Marge
lately like where was Marge when all
this was going on I don't know I'm just
I'm just saying I'm just saying it just
seems like you know uh maybe maybe
there's an explosion here but watch this
this tape of this house exploding in
Arlington
Virginia
[__] that's some crazy
[__]
[Music]
FU oh now apparently yesterday uh the
gentleman that was in this house was
barricaded in the house and he was
shooting like uh flares I guess and they
had the bomb squad
and and law enforcement was there when
they approached the house he was firing
a firearm at him apparently I don't
know but let's watch it one more time
Texas Paul because I don't know I like
watching [__] blown up let's watch it
maybe if it'll load son of a [__] hang
on a second you ever had this problem I
have this
problem here here's the video of the
house getting blown up in Arlington
Virginia just to pipe bombs walk away
from Washington
DC Tony I got a little audio problem
here I'm not getting any audio feed
[Music]
in
holy are you not are is your mic not
working can you hear me
now I go out and come back in go out and
come back in I don't know Texas Paul's
having trouble with this new microphone
I guess maybe maybe go out and come back
in um but this this bomb apparently it's
what it looks like to me now I don't
know if he had the gas on or what the
[__] but um again this is just uh again
let me show you this one more time this
is a pipe bomb's walk away from
Washington DC take a
[Music]
look holy [__] [__] of course that's
the that's the reaction holy [__]
[__] yeah this went this went crazy on
the internet yesterday now this guy
apparently he was shooting
flares um now
uh M mom's Russo on um twitch makes a
good point meth house um this is what
can happen if you're cooking meth inside
of a house it can explode most of the
time it is not this um visceral of a
explosion a lot of times it just starts
a it's an explosion it starts a fire but
um I don't maybe this guy had bombs
maybe I don't know I don't know what the
hell happened but um my question is has
anyone checked on Marge
[Music]
lately and the petty yetis there let's
see if we can get Paul back in here Paul
oh man how do I sound brother I for some
reason it picked up my uh it picked up
my my earbuds as my mic and then when I
changed that it wouldn't use my earbuds
as speakers I don't crazy I see I see I
see well you did I did I did question
whether your new mic was actually uh on
or not that's why I asked if you had a
new mic um and I actually I have a video
um rat can you can you put that um let's
see let me see if I can find this video
here let me see if I can find this video
of your new mic on your show the other
day because I want I want to show the
audience this and I know you'll enjoy
this Texas Paul I know you enjoy this I
I I you're gonna embarrass me aren't you
no no no I would I would never I would
never do such a thing yes you would and
you'd enjoy the [__] out of it why in
the hell would you think I would
embarrass you I would never I would
never do that to you because you live
for it well here's the thing here's the
thing I want the audience to um to judge
for themselves you know this is just
this is just a clip um that was taken
from your show and I and I just want to
make sure the audience um they they
judge for themselves I I I don't want to
prejudge this I don't want to um um you
know make assumptions about this like I
made about your your microphone uh what
the hell why isn't it doing this why
isn't it going how do I sound do I sound
better now I mean oh you sound you sound
perfect everything sounds great okay
great it sounds great um here is the um
here's the video all right now I got it
let's see if we
can it hasn't been around you know since
since before Christ was born but
okay what what was that Texas PA
no wait a wait a second wait a second
wait a second let me let me
listen like it hasn't been around you
this s before Christ was born but
okay I didn't add no audio I did not the
only thing no no no no no no no everyone
could go look at this I I just alls I
did was clip it I'm just making see if
the audience agrees with me take a
listen
again
that's let's do it one more time like it
hasn't been around you know since since
before Christ was born but
okay Tas Paul I how do you I I mean
looks listen I I I I get flatulence here
on the show too that was not flatulence
D that was not flatulence you know damn
well you edited a fart into that no I
didn't I did not edit any of that audio
now I clipped it I certainly did clip it
from the show that someone um someone I
don't know who it was um sent it to me
who was watching your show and said that
maybe just maybe that your new
microphone had picked up some noise from
the room and I was like oh baby I I need
to have that because I might have to see
if the audience thinks um what they know
is the truth I look listen Paul I am
just I am just the postman for the truth
I just deliver it I don't I don't read
the mail I don't put the the letter in
the envelope I don't pack the bills I
don't lick the envelope I don't put the
stamp on it I just deliver it my friend
it's all I
do Texas Paul Texas Paul I promise you I
didn't edit that that audio I promise
you first of all that wasn't me that was
not me busting ass if I'd been busting
ass the mic would have fluttered and
moved around the room
and you know you you would know if I
busted ass I'm telling you you would not
it wouldn't be it would be uh you know
something more kin to an A10 warthog
zooming in on a tank man you know I mean
you what what would would all all those
books on the Shelf be melted back there
is that what you're saying is it uh you
have to melted [__] they wouldn't be on
the Shelf you'd have to You' have you
you have a special room that you go to
to uh to to
let me tell you something I'm old and a
lot of [__] don't work like it used to
but the colon is still working brother
the colon is still working okay so yeah
there it
is theren says who gives a fart who
gives a fart who gives a fart Julie says
just Own It Texas Paul I mean the
comments are flooding in here I think
this is good content Texas Paul um and
you know what you know what I will send
you I will I will send you the um the
the original video and I will send you
the video so that you can determine it
uh JD actually asked is it real or is it
AI I couldn't tell you if uh if Texas
Paul used AI to insert the fart into his
show or not I just cut the clip um
Regina says I'm up to no good they were
all on to me Texas PA even you were on
to me even you were on to
me all right let's get back to real
business here enough of enough of that
farting [__]
let's get to um comr what do you think
of comr pile do you think he really
stepped in it this time um with this
$4,100 uh truck down payment I mean
Texas Paul you got to be the worst money
launderer in the world if you think that
you loan someone $4,100 for a truck
payment and they pay you back that exact
amount without interest and you think
that's somehow money laundering or
something you got to be one of the worst
money launderers in the world actually
the worst laundering in the world might
laugh at you to how bad you are at
moneya laundering what do you think yeah
I mean I I think that they comr is just
doing that same [__] that Republicans do
just keep throwing [__] out and throwing
[__] out and throwing [__] out and his
his folks eat it up they do they're like
oh yeah that's exactly what it is they
oh yeah that's money laundering gotta be
because that's what they want to hear
man that's what they want to hear it's
just the same old tired [__] over and
over and over again they're just going
to keep saying [__] until you know the
old Geral repeat it tell a lie tell a
big lie and keep repeating it over and
over and over again until it becomes
truth I mean that that's all that that's
all this is and it's getting nowhere
with us it's getting he's getting no
traction outside his party with any of
this here's the actual picture of Hunter
Biden buying the truck
it's a Ford Raptor um which is a pretty
sweet truck if you want to know the
honest truth um it's not a it's not a
bad it's not a bad vehicle I'm I'm I'm
I'm more of a Chevrolet fan than a Ford
fan that's just kind of my preference um
but this Ford Raptor they're they're
some badass [__] trucks but here's
here's Hunter Biden shaking the
salesman's hand with Joe Biden with him
so it's not like they were hiding this
like they went to the dealership
together Joe Biden probably wrote the
check for the down payment at the
dealership and then Hunter Biden paid
him back the exact amount I think it's
$4,175 to be exact he paid him back in
like three payments over a few months
the exact amount with no interest now
Texas Paul what comr is claiming is that
somehow this is this is U evidence that
Joe Biden should be impeached for some
sort of Chinese payment now the problem
is is in this picture this picture here
is from
2018 can you tell me what office Joe
Biden held in 2018 do you have to Google
it oh oh oh so you're saying what what's
funny about this this is the most
hilarious thing about this narrative
that the Republicans are trying to spend
is that the the [__] the [__] four
years the four years that Joe Biden
hadn't held office basically his an
entire adult life his entire adult life
the four years that he did not hold
public office they're saying he did all
the money laundering during that four
years that he didn't hold public office
they can't find an instance where he
held public office and he did this only
after he held public office is when
they're finding it but the other the
other crazy part about this is this
picture is on social media they weren't
hiding it they weren't hiding that that
Joe Biden helped him buy this truck
there there was none of
that yeah
money first of all the money needs to be
laundered I mean if if you're going to
launder money second of all nobody
launders four
grand
nobody nobody launders four grand I mean
Ju Just just the fines
alone uh from from from the IRS would
negate any benefit from laundering for
Grand I mean it's just this is the
stupidest thing I have ever heard I mean
really I get the concept I do I get the
concept keep repeating [__] over and
over again call them the Biden crime
family you know all the same narrative
just stay on target repeat it repeat it
repeat it repeat it repeat it and it'll
eventually get traction hopefully well
it's not working and they're getting
stupider and stupider and stupider and
stupider because there's just not real
[__] to put out there and that's why I
absolutely love that Hunter Biden said I
will absolutely come testify before your
committee but we're doing it in public
because over and over and over again
they've done this [__] where they look
at things behind closed doors they pull
a bill bar they
mischaracterize what they saw what they
what they heard they lie about
it and then every time we dig into it
and it's time to show the cards it's
it's [__] over and over and over
again well here's some of the here's
some of here's some of the [__] last
night on Rob Schmid show on Newsmax
listen listen to comr py trying to make
sense of this so it was no skin off Joe
Biden's back you know when my son needs
help or my daughter who's in college
needs help I just give her money nobody
ever pays me back
but so so it's because Hunter paid him
back the same amount that he gave him is
the reason why this is bribery I don't
understand what the bribe is I don't get
it I don't understand what the what's
the bribe that Hunter Biden got a truck
I don't understand what what the [__]
he's talking about maybe maybe this will
clear it up maybe this will clear it up
this little clip from Fox News he was
making a little different argument here
listen to this one reason we wanted to
pose Hunter bid we want to say what did
you do to receive this income if it was
in fact lobbying if he was a lobbyist
for China then that's that's called a
foreign agent and he's an unregistered
foreign agent and that's a that's a
penalty of up to five years impr
prisonment and $250,000 fine and Joe
Biden then was receiving direct benefit
from his son being an unregistered
foreign agent so you could make a strong
argument that Joe Biden violated the far
laws as well okay so now they're saying
it's a a a far law um violation which is
the the foreign agent registration act
um where you have to register as a
foreign agent here's the problem here's
the problem Hunter Biden and his company
is is registered properly he does
consult with companies in China that's
how he makes his money and what they're
claiming is here's what they're claiming
Texas Paul is because Hunter Biden used
money from his personal
business than to payback Joe Biden for
the truck that Joe Biden did their down
payment for that's somehow Joe Biden
getting Chinese money in the form of
$4,100 hours now the craziest part is we
literally have went from $4 million
originally to the Biden family to 10
million to 20 million to $40 million
I've had I've listened to Congress
people say $40 million Donald Trump s on
stage the other night five billion
billion dollar billion dollar we went
from that to $200,000 that Joe Biden
received no interest on a loan from his
brother which is terrible money
laundering as well and also now we're
down to 40 100 bucks on a down payment
on a Raptor Ford pickup truck that's
where we're at that that somehow some
way that this is this big grand scheme
that Hunter Biden and Joe Biden have
used to get $4,100 of Chinese money in
Joe Biden's pocket now this is really
stupid because the problem is is Joe
Biden gave Hunter Biden
$4,175 and then Hunter Biden gave him
back 41 75 so Joe Biden just got
different money that's not how money
works either folks that's not how it
[__] works everyone knows that and
Texas Paul I actually think that this
narrative is going to help in the effort
to show that Joe Biden is not corrupt
like this narrative that they're forming
is going to show that he loves his son
he helped him out with a pickup truck
payment and Hunter Biden paid him back
and they moved on down the road no pun
intended yeah I just over and over and
over I did a whole video on how
Consulting works why the you have bank
accounts in the countries that you do
Consulting for I mean if you and I are
working to get a Consulting contract and
you Tony say well you know I will only
do business with bank accounts in
Missouri and I say uh okay Mr you Mr
whatever whoever pick a country uh Mr
abas in in Jordan I will gladly come to
Jordan set up a bank account in Jordan
make it easy for you to do business Mr
Mr abas I'm glad to do that for you as I
provide you Consulting Services that's
how it works that is how it works so
when I transfer money out of that
account to pay people it's G to come
from freaking Jordan that's how it works
that's what the man does for a living is
consult for people
especially his company
specializes in helping people that are
in difficult political
situations for instance the Ukraine just
had had Revolution re had had a
revolution they were cleaning up their
act he consulted for barisma on how to
get Western
financing what your company has to do to
meet the requirements to do business in
the west that that's what he does for a
living that's why he was working you
they keep saying well what what what
knowledge does he have to work for an
oil company he's not an oil man no he
helped them with financing but he he is
a money guy that's what he does
right that's why that's where the
freaking checks come from and that's the
big thing that keeps blowing up in
Comer's face he keeps painting these
hyperbolic narratives over and over
again oh my God it's this that and the
other and then when they say okay here's
the check we spent for the truck here's
the three checks that he paid me back
with their even amounts of money uh the
truck here's the
registration for the truck the truck was
real you know I mean here's us buying
the truck and it blows up in their face
so freaking
hard James comr has zero credibility he
you could literally catch Joe Biden in
the middle of robbing a bank literally
robbing a bank and if the witness was
James
Homer he would
walk he would
walk I don't doubt that a bit my
audience is so smart Andre here on
YouTube they're so smart because they
you know what they've they've gotten
this idea that they have to stay ahead
of right-wing narratives and Andrea is
doing that here she's like Hunter pay
back the exact amount to throw them off
like that's that's going to be another
stupid talking point that they have that
that yes that's why paid them back the
exact amount as to throw throw them off
a what and Andrea is right she rolls her
eyes she's being sarcastic here but
that's
exactly what the right wi's gonna say
but here's another talking point from
from comr pile here you can loan people
money if they pay you back then you you
benefited directly from the influence
ping te because what what so so he's
saying you can loan people money and if
they pay you back then you benefited
from it but only if they pay you
interest that's the only benefit you get
from it other than other than Joe Biden
got to help his son like that's the
actual benefit that Joe Biden got out of
this is his son was down in his luck at
the time he was recovering from his
[__] his addiction right which these
Republicans should really really really
um check their addiction to Hunter Biden
they are so [__] addicted to Hunter
Biden it's not even funny now what James
comr here is saying is that if you loan
someone money and they pay you the exact
amount back then you benefited from it
what the [__] is he talking about is
this really his [__] evidence this is
the evidence that he's going with he
thinks the American people are gonna buy
this [__]
really yeah because MAA people do buy
this [__] because most of them haven't
been out of their own damn County much
less understand international business
and and Banking and how it works you
know the
but Texas Paul you don't need to
understand international business to
understand that I gave I gave my child
my kid a down payment of a truck and
they paid me back over a few months you
don't need a lot of [__] that's what
I'm saying about this narrative is you
know months ago when they were talking
about four million 10 million 20 million
40 million they were doing this thing
with like oh all these shell companies
and there's this barisma and see this
thing here and they were talking all
this crazy [__] that sounds really
stupid because it is sound smart right
they got to say a lot of stupid [__] to
sound smart but this is not that kind of
narrative this is Joe Biden loaned his
son 4,100 bucks for a down payment on a
truck and Hunter Biden paid him back
that 4,100 bucks most people in this
country understand that it doesn't take
a it doesn't take a a a long
dissertation to explain it it you don't
need a [__] diagram to show what
happened like literally they understand
this stuff and and it's so crazy it's so
crazy that they don't see that their
narrative is about to [__] the bed
because watch this watch this is crazy
too you got a lot of people including
here's a tweet from an analyst that says
that these are just uh payments already
reported in the media for a truck that
Joe Biden bought for his son he says I
don't think fronting a son money for a
truck is an impeachable offense he says
another swing and a miss your response
to that that's bull crap look if if he
wanted to send his money to his son for
a truck then sending money for his truck
but he got paid back from China so it no
he got paid back from Hunter Biden's
business who consults other businesses
in China China this is so stupid this is
so dumb and again again I would love I
would love for this to be some sort of
intrical thing where they're talking
stupid to sound smart again but they
have lost the plot so much the plot has
slipped through their fingers Texas
pulse
and and the reason why is because the
desperation for Trump that's the reason
why the plot has slipped through their
fingers Texas Paul is the desperation
for Trump because they needed
desperately to paint Joe Biden as a
crook this entire time and now it's
becoming clear that he's he's the exact
opposite of what the House GOP is saying
well they got in their own mediate
bubble for so long they don't understand
they can't understand why it's playing
like I was saying you're absolutely
right as to why it's going to fall apart
but to their people to MAA who can't
hold up their paycheck and tell you what
all the little alphabet soup means they
don't know any they're not sophisticated
people Tony they aren't so if you tell
them the money came from China it came
from
China to them it's nefarious because
like I said they've never been outside
their damn County they don't understand
doing business in China that you would
have a bank account in China so so yes
the money would come from freaking China
because that's where you're doing
business at the time he's a consultant
man he's not a freaking manufacturer
he's not a factory for him to make his
product he has to be working in China so
that's where his business is going to be
when he's there Consulting for a company
in China he's also consulted for people
in Europe he's also consultant for
people here in the United States you set
up the bank accounts where you're
working
for the ease of your client period it's
that simple but these simpletons like I
said can't hold up a damn paycheck and
say okay what does what is f IA what is
fic why are they taking thicker out of
my paycheck you I mean they don't get it
Tony they're not sophisticated people
now your
audience they understand they know the
these are people that know I mean they
understand not only what f is but they
know what the damn acronym means you
know I mean they they they know why the
law was put in place in the first place
they know why they're paying that MAA
not so much not so much and they and the
Republicans like you said they've lost
the they've they' they've lost it they
don't understand why the hell isn't this
[__] sticking to the wall we keep
throwing it why ain't it sticky you know
well it ain't sticky enough [__] it
ain't it ain't it ain't Texas Paul fart
shows type [__] it it's just not that
sticky it's just not that
sticky look at this look at this picture
that we got here of private comr pile
here um I don't know if you've seen the
movie Full Metal Jacket um but
apparently um private private comr pile
was in in that movie apparently U maybe
we'll have to go back and refresh and
look at that but apparently he was in
that movie I love that Nick name I don't
know who came up with comr pile but I
[__] I [__] love it I [__] love
it um let's see what what do we what do
we got here oh here we go this um
apparently we have a picture of the
um this is a Texas Paul Sonic Boom
apparently um is what this is Apparently
that is not feathers behind Texas Paul
that is the sonic boom that happens when
he has a new mic ra phone on and it's
picking up room noise all right actually
I you know what I think I think uh
streamyard has a real bad habit of
trying to switch over to the my earbuds
mic that's what you were hearing when I
was moving my earbud I I don't even
think I was running on my new mic that
that show that's a damn shame is that
what it is is that what it is how do I
sound by the way I mean I just a fortune
on of my you sound you sound great now
you sound great now we're not picking up
the room farts um today uh they picking
up no well hey go ahead if you got one
I'll shoot another one of these down and
I'll
that's Texas fall sonic
boom that's what we deliver here on
Tuesdays and taco Tuesday when it's Taco
Tuesday it's Texas Paul Sonic Boom
Tuesday as well talking about Sonic
booms oh boy Liz Cheney is a sonic boom
every you know now my my audience knows
where I'm coming from with Liz ch they
understand this they get it they know
she's no [__] hero they know she's no
Alli to liberalism or liberal democracy
for that matter and there's news um in
the Washington Post let me bring it up
here here it is Liz Cheney told the
Washington Post she's considering a
third-party presidential bid to stop
Trump we Face the threats that could be
exential to United States and we need a
candidate who is going to be able to
deal with and address and confront all
those challenges would you vote for her
[__] no I wouldn't vote for
her again they're so [__] desperate
they're so [__] desperate and I've
been saying this time and time and time
again do not do not act like Liz Cheney
is your [__] Ally Liz Cheney is no
[__] Allied to democracy and this
book tour is just for profit it is not
to apologize to the American people
which she should and it is not to make
sure that America understands the threat
because it's not it is for profit I want
to show you a little clip here from
Rachel mattow show last night on this
very topic and I'm going to I'm going to
stop it a few times and break down what
Liz Cheney is saying and why the [__]
she wasn't ask certain questions I
respect Rachel mattow and I know that
Rachel mattow probably was under
contract and she really wanted to have
Liz Cheney on for the ratings but let me
tell you something not asking certain
question is dereliction of Rachel mattow
Duty as far as I'm concerned and I'm
disappointed but let me let me play a
little bit of this clip let me ask you
about um a moment in your book that
happens on January 4th it's described in
chapter nine of your book and you
describ listening in on a call um in
which Trump lawyers are briefing um what
we call surrogate so it's basically
people are going to go on TV and talk
about the pro Trump side of things yeah
and on that call La Trump lawyer Jenna
Ellis describes what they're envisioning
for January 6 she says the way you write
it is in the scenario Ellis described
when Pence was presiding he could either
refuse to open or refuse to count the
electoral votes okay and this is what
Jenna Ellis has pled guilty to in
Georgia this is the very exact plan this
was their plan in Georgia this is what
she's pled guilty to this is what she's
give proffers this is what she's give
deposition to in opposition of trump she
has turned on Trump in this form and
fashion and she was telling people out
loud at the time what their plan was
including Liz jany now Texas Paul in
this clip Liz Cheney is saying that they
did not know she was on this call which
I think is a bold-faced liee I think it
is a lie that that that they did not
think that house leadership was on this
call as surrogates in the media I think
that's a [__] lie but listen to this
they don't necessarily know you're on
this call you're listening in two days
before January 6 was that the moment
when it really became clear to you in
detail what they were going to try to do
uh yes
you know okay all right so I think it's
a lie that they didn't know she was on
the call I think that's a bunch of
[__] listen folks I don't I don't I
don't know if you know how this works
but when these [__] scumbags have
these meetings on these live calls where
they have surrogates Republicans are
damn good at talking points they're damn
good at it they do it all the time every
[__] day they have these [__]
calls where they get these surrogates
that's how their messaging stays
together that's how they get that's how
they [__] keep it all together and
glue all the stupidity on that you see
on the rightwing media that I show you
here that's how they get it all together
now the think that Liz Cheney the third
in line in the Republican caucus at the
time wasn't on that call is is just dumb
to me it's ridiculous that is ridiculous
that they did not believe that that
house leadership was not on that call
now the most significant thing is this
is January 4th Texas Paul this is
January 4th and when she hears Jenna
Ellis say this now she's lowering it
down into a few words but when she hears
Jenna Ellis lay out this plan Liz Cheney
says that's the moment where she
realized what they were gonna do that's
the moment not after January 6 before
January 6 okay now I want to remind
people that it took Liz Cheney 190 days
let me say it again 190 days from the
election to go to the house floor as
house leadership in the Republican
caucus to say that Donald Trump had lost
remember that in this moment now I had
heard obviously there had been talk
about uh we're going to have these
electors meet I think Steph Miller had
been talking about that but it wasn't
clear to me um what the the Contours of
this particular part of the plan were um
until I dialed into that phone call and
listening to them describe how these
fake electors were going to be used and
um the fact that they anticipated that
vice president
was going to use them to refuse to count
the legitimate electors was certainly a
moment of of uh intense concern and and
as I got off that call I ran into the
capital uh into the office of the
parliamentarian of the house to say you
know wait a minute this is what I'm
hearing is going to happen what do we do
about it in the joint session how do we
stop this and okay so Liz Cheney is so
concerned on January 4th that she ran to
the
parliamentarian in the house and was so
concerned but she didn't say anything to
the American people not a [__] peep
not a [__] Peep and the reason why
Texas Paul is because this is all Liz
Cheney is doing Liz Cheney M made sure
this was what could happen she made sure
Trump was in power she made sure to to
be an ally with Trump she made sure to
prop up the big lie in December that oh
he has all this right to to exhaust any
legal remedies and went and continued on
and on and on to capitulate to the big
line Texas Paul that's what that's what
she did that's what she did and she it
took her 190 days at the election this
is after she knows she knows what
they're going to do it took her 190 days
to get to the floor of the house to say
that Donald Trump had lost is Liz Cheney
our Ally should we should we really be
making her into the hero
here she's not a hero and she's not an
ally but I'll give her this much because
you know I was actually thinking about
this before at breakfast this this
morning we went and running erands we
sat and had breakfast and I was sitting
at the table and I was thinking about it
because you know the wife had told me
she she wanted me to cover the whole mat
interview so I was thinking about it and
I'll give Liz Cheney this much and this
much only if the roles were
reversed and the existence poal threat
to our democracy was a
Democrat it would not be a comfortable
thing for me I would do
it I would hate it but I would do
it to trash the standard bearer of your
party if for some
reason just hypothetical here I'm not
talking about actual woman if Harris for
whatever reason came out totally we done
with these Republicans screw it when I
elected in 2008 that's it I'm going to
rig this so that they those sons of
[__] will never be in power
again man that would be an uncomfortable
place for me to be in it really would
because I'm you I don't lie about it I
don't lie about my bias my bias I am a
died in the I am the founder of the ride
or die Democrats so yeah I'll give her
that much rolles reversed I understand
her discomfort that she's in I I'll give
her that much but no she you were right
she is no freaking hero she is nobody's
savior in a heartbeat if it was her
daddy she would be carrying the water in
a freaking water truck man you know I
mean she just she know she is
not The
Virtuous friendly I don't know the right
word here Tony she's not the person you
want in the Foxhole with you be glad
she's not shooting back at you but she
is not the person you want behind you in
a foxhole she's just not well I'm glad
you brought that up because Liz Cheney
will fire back at us and that that is my
point and that is what I'm trying to
tell people is Liz Cheney is doing this
for one of two reasons and one of two
reasons only it's this one that James
says [__] you pay me I want my money for
my book which I believe that's one of
the reasons but the other reason you're
here is that Liz Cheney wants her party
back because listen to what she says
here in this interview um and it was
very clear that uh there were not a lot
of good answers to that because I knew I
learned later through the investigation
that vice president Pence and his
Council were having discussions with the
Senate parliamentarian and that the vice
president you know ultimately of course
did his duty bravely um but if you're in
a joint session of Congress you know
you're you're not in a position where uh
there are a lot of legislative steps
that you can take uh except to to
basically you know move to a journ uh so
it was a very dangerous and chilling
moment yeah in in that moment when it
started to become clear to you what
might happen did it strike you as an
insane thing they were going to try
which therefore might create a chaotic
situation or did it strike you that this
is something that might actually succeed
in effectively toppling the government
you know I had been I had been getting
these hints you know through the months
after the election of sort of glimpses
into things that um that they were
attempting to do and okay here we go and
this is the leadup to it Texas Paul I
was getting hints this she is not some
outlier in this situation this is Liz
[__] Cheney this is Darth Vader Jr
okay she was third in line in the house
leadership of the Republican caucus she
wasn't just some a [__] Observer
that's all [__] and that's why I
[__] can't stand this [__] because
she's [__] lying here this is a lie
this is a boldfaced [__] lie and for
Rachel mat to say stop not to say stop
stop stop stop stop stop what are you
talking about you were third in line you
were third in house leadership it was
only Steve scal and Kevin McCarthy ahead
of you what are you talking about that
you were observing you were observing
your leadership what do you mean you
were observing listen and each time sort
of I I saw something come up and I kept
thinking and I think a lot of us kept
thinking all right look you know he's
going to bring these Court challenges
but of course once the courts have ruled
he will concede and we'll move on and
and each time you thought we were at an
end we weren't really at an end and so I
think this this was probably the most
chilling moment where it was suddenly
real that you know this wasn't just some
sort of appeal our effort to suggest
that he hadn't lost the election there
was a very real plan um to stop us from
Counting legitimate electoral votes and
that again Texas Paul is a [__] lie
she knew the plan because she pointed at
Jim Jordan said you did this
[__] I mean hell in her book she
describes that they were saying you're
you're turning your back on us you're
supposed to be our girlfriend they were
saying and she said I'm not your
girlfriend the this is [__] lies lies
lies lies lies and I'm not surprised
that Liz chanie is lying to if you want
to know the honest truth and the reason
why Liz Cheney is lying to you the
audience to America is because she
doesn't want people to know that she
[__] caused this that's what this is
this is a [__] book PR tour for Liz
Cheney to sell herself to us as some
kind of [__] hero for democracy and
she was in on it she was [__] in on
it and it didn't work and when it didn't
work and it didn't work in her favor for
her [__] power she turned on them and
when she turned on him they turned on
her and that's the [__] truth this is
a [__] lie you can never you can
never convince me that Liz Cheney Dick
Cheney's daughter who is a congress the
only Congress person from [__]
Wyoming third in line third in power
only Steve scales and Kevin McCarthy a
of her in house leadership did not know
this [__] and she was not part of this
[__] effort to [__] sell the big
lie to us I got evidence of it she was
[__] on TV selling the big [__]
lie she knew it she [__] knew it the
whole time she knew it wasn't no PR
campaign she knew he wasn't going to
concede she knows who the [__] he is she
knows he's a [__] Manchild and a baby
she knows his ego [__] that [__] this is
a lie it's a [__] lie I'm sorry I
just don't believe a goddamn word of it
may maybe maybe people out there can and
will but I don't sorry Texas Paul I just
don't believe this no the only
difference between her and everybody
else in the Republican Party the default
position in the Republican party is well
let's see if he can get away with it and
when he couldn't get away with it he was
expected to do what was best for the
party and just quietly you know
acknowledge that he lost do the best you
can to save face for the party and move
on that's where Liz sheney and the
Republican Party split ways I mean she
was cool with him hey do the best you
can if you can get away with it great
you know we'll support you but the
minute it was obvious that he was
failing he was supposed to say okay I
lost and the rest of the Republican
party was screw this fight to the death
Liz cheny was like no no we're not no
we're not doing that it wasn't that she
wasn't part of it she absolutely was
part of it it was just that moment that
they they broke ways and Liz Cheney now
I believe is looking at Donald Trump she
knows Donald Trump is the end of what is
today's Republican party they are dead
she is positioning herself come to Mama
I I'm the future I'm the head of the
Republican party I'm the one that told
you I'm the one that that that that that
suffered the slings and arrows
while you people all coddled this son of
a [__] I'm the one you have to follow
that is that is her endgame here is to
be the future of the Republican party
not our freaking
Ally uh Johanna asked a question here
okay Tony so what's new we can all we
can all can figure it out okay so the
the new part is is that what Texas Paul
is saying what Texas Paul is saying I'm
going to take it a step further Le CH is
positioning herself to try to be the
third party candidate here um now I
don't think it's going to happen Joe
Manson [__] the bed I don't know if you
guys know that Joe mansion and no labels
[__] the [__] bed Joe Mansion was
gonna resign as Senator not rerun he was
going to do a national interview which
he did and he was going to be catapulted
to this Presidential nominee of No
Labels and it [__] the bed because no
one gives a [__] about Joe Mansion no
one gives a [__] about No Labels no one
knows what the [__] no labels and no one
wants to vote for a party that has no
label what are you talking about No
Label so what are you for well we're for
nothing it's a show about nothing it's
nothing we're H we just we're about
nothing we're about nothing we got
nothing okay so what the [__] are you
and that's the point that Liz jany is
trying to do she's trying to do a PR
tour to [__] to make sure that the
American people do not blame her for
Trump and that she can be elevated as a
third party candidate that's what's
happening here that I I [__] I now it
will [__] the bed and the reason why
it'll [__] the bed is cuz people like me
aren't going to [__] let her get away
with it I ain't going to get let you get
away with your [__] lies I don't care
what goddamn cable channel you're on I
don't care what host you're with here's
more of this Rachel M interview real
quick Texas Paul you know there was a
moment right after uh January 6 where I
was having dinner with my husband and
our two youngest kids um who happen to
be our sons and and I looked at my sons
across the dinner table and and I had
this realization you know I grew up in a
country where I didn't have to wonder if
we were going to have a peaceful
transfer of power in the United States
and all of a sudden it occurred to me my
God maybe they won't be able to say the
same thing and and that is why it's so
fundamentally important that we we
ensure Democrats Independents
Republicans that we we work together we
vote together we make clear that Donald
Trump is not an acceptable alternative
he is not the lesser of two evils he is
a completely UNF fit man for office he's
already shown us what he would do and he
could never be near the Oval Office
again everyone was saying this in 2016
in 2020 when Liz Cheney was backing
Trump when Dick Cheney was backing Trump
when they were in for Trump when they
were voting with him 90% of the time
they wanted him as the stooge in the
white house so they could wet ink
anything that they wanted the tax cuts
for the [__] Rich they wanted to get
rid of America's ability to [__] have
Healthcare they want to get rid of
decent [__] wages in this country
they want to destroy the ability for
women to have the right to healthcare
and to privacy in a [__] doctor's
office it's all [__] this is all
[__] [__] for you to sit there
and say days after January 6 after the
email lady which that's one [__]
person that Liz Cheney owns a goddamn
apology to because [__] Hillary
Clinton was saying this [__] the same
[__] Liz Cheney is doing a national
[__] PR book tour for she was saying
the same [__] in 2016 and everyone was
saying the same [__] about Donald Trump
in the opposition to him in 2016 to 2020
and this [__] piece of sludge this
piece of [__] sludge was [__]
following him and supporting him and in
and making sure that he was elevated to
power that's what she was doing and then
oh my god when everything that the crazy
[__] leftist said that would come
true all the email lady said that would
come true when all that [__] came true
then she changed her [__] mind
didn't she changed her [__] mind no
she didn't no she didn't she knew it the
whole time Texas Paul she knew tell you
though um running as a third party
candidate against the Republican ticket
is going to be Crossing the Rubicon for
her that that will
be the end of her plan to you know she's
got this Phoenix resur Resurrection plan
um if she she pulls the mirror opposite
of Joe mansion and runs run on a third
party against Trump she's not just
running against Trump she's running
against the Republican party at that
point and there will be no coming back
for her ever I think that's going to be
the largest tactical because right now
she's selling I did it all for the party
I did it all for us she can sell that in
the future she can she can say look how
bad this when everything collapses when
he's convicted when all of this happens
she can all she can always say I did it
all for us if she runs against the
Republicans in 24 she's done well done I
agree with you there but here's the
thing is that Liz Cheney is also
postulating in these interviews uh I
wish I had a a good quick clip of it I
think she says it in this one with
Savannah Guthrie in the end let me see
if I can find it here um but Liz Cheney
actually is postulating that the
Republican party is actually dead that
it can't be revived that they can't go
back the re and they can't they can't
can't undo this [__] you can't undo that
you tried to attempt a coup that you use
the house the house caucus to try and
and Republican Senators to try to
attempt the coup that you try to use
State parties and state legislators uh
to try to get fake electors uh in
Washington you tried to use the vice
president who is a republican at the
time to actually attempt this coup and
that's the thing is they can't stuff
that cat back in the bag the Republican
party is dead the dead it's it's the
actual problem that we have in the
country Texas Paul the problem isn't
that we're divided that's all [__]
we are not divided 50/50 that is all
horseshit most people in this country
want decent [__] wages they don't
want to go broke because of a medical
bill they don't want their children to
go broke because they got to go to
[__] college and and they just want
to live their [__] lives the way that
they want to [__] live them that's
the majority consensus in this country
all those culture wars have already been
fought and won by the people and the
majority in in this country that's the
[__] truth there's only about 10 12
maybe up to 23% in this country that
don't agree with that [__] that want to
be oligarchs that want to control people
and and it's the and it's the majority
of that 12% that are the sheep that
follow those
[__] and here's the thing
here's the thing is a Republican party
is dead and we have a two-party system
and we only have one party that's
interested in democracy that's it there
only one party that's interested in
governing anywhere in in count in States
and school boards in the federal
government they're the only ones that
are willing to govern for the people
that is the trouble that we have let me
see if I can find this clip of her
talking about how the Republican party
is dead and it's not gonna do it it's
not gonna do it that was a great Point
by the way I was listening to you in the
car on the way in trying to make sure I
was caught up on everything um you know
when I was rushing to get home to be
here um yeah that that's a outstanding
point we have a government that's
designed to run with two political
parties and we only have one functioning
party one party does not know how nor
does it want to govern they
are I don't even know what to classify
the Republican party as anymore all you
know they're just bomb throwers it's you
know that they are the freedom caucus
through and through I mean there there's
no
functioning Wing I mean everybody likes
to to poke at our you know our eggh
heads the ones we love to death Katie
Porter uh Elizabeth Warren yeah those
people know how to govern you know they
they they're willing to do the boring
work of looking at you know governmental
minutia and doing the job there's no
Republican out there on the other side
that wants to govern I mean really
governing is not fun people it's not
it's it's a job and a boring one at that
you know you've got to elect people that
want to do it and and I love that Paul
Young Eggheads rule absolutely they do I
mean you know the the talkers are one
thing the you know the the figureheads
that get out there and and and throw you
know the the bomb throwers are fun to
watch but it's the guys and gals that
sit in the back room and make the deals
and look at you know just line by line
legislation those are the ones that make
the the country run there are no
Republicans to do that Richie brings up
a point here so let's use Liz to get it
done that's my point is that's what I'm
trying to tell folks is Liz is not the
weapon to use to get it done she's not
because number one she hasn't said the
truth yet until Liz Cheney gets to the
real truth that she was the problem and
she elevated this thing to power it was
the Republican party and their thin
veiled Fascism and they thin veil it
with conservatism for years is what
brought this on this white Christian
nationalism she won't admit that [__]
and if she won't admit it all that
[__] that she's selling in that book
falls on deaf ears 100% if she won't get
with the [__] truth and she won't
tell us the [__] truth then it's all
lies and it won't matter and if we use
her and her lies to weaponize against
them to save democracy it might just
kill our [__] democracy democracy is
not one with lies folks autocracy is one
with lies autocracy is the foundation
the foundation of autocracy is deceit
delusion lies and [__] fraud and
fascism the foundation of democracy is
the [__] truth it's strength it's
liberalism I don't give a [__] how you
shake it how you want to mold it the
problem is is that Liz Cheney is not
doing what she is doing in good faith
she's doing it to revitalize her Public
Image that's what she's doing [__] me
that's it [__] you pay me she wants to
be paid for that
b and that's the problem is we can't use
Liz to get it done because her entire
narrative and the entire Foundation is
based in a false narrative it's
misinformation she's not telling you the
[__] whole truth she knows the
[__] whole truth she was there she
was sitting with Kevin McCarthy she was
sitting with Steve scalise Jesus Christ
how many times you think her ass was in
the White House listen to Donald Trump
puke up this [__] do you think she was
just an outcast the entire time no she
was an integral part of the Trump
presidency that was the whole [__]
point in the first place of them making
sure she he was their buffoon with a wet
pen and that's the point I'm trying to
make Richie is I wish we could use Liz I
wish Liz was the weapon we could use and
we could we could if she got with the
truth if she got with the [__] truth
William Griffin right there in the chat
just nailed it just freaking nailed it
she's Mike Pence in aess absolutely Mike
Pence the what came out about his
testimony to Jack Smith this guy lied
his ass off he said oh I talked I I you
know I talked to Dan my friend Dan quail
and I decided I couldn't do the [__]
he talked to Dan quail and he decided he
was gonna let it happen by not showing
up and then he told his to have face
Toof face discussion with his Marine son
and explain him why he was not going to
be there certifying the vat his son said
no no you took the same damn oath I did
to protect the
Constitution and his son shamed him into
showing up we're talking right up to the
last damn minute Mike Pence was on the
exact same train that LZ Cheney was on
you're absolutely right they were on the
same damn train if they can get away
with this cool cool right the minute
they couldn't get away with it you had
Adam kenzinger you had Liz Cheney and
those folks say look he's going to go
down here we have to cast him off we
have to walk away and the rest of the
Republicans are authoritarian [__]
and they're all like no we fight to the
end we fight to the end 2025 project
we're GNA be fascists and Liz Cheney is
like we have been fascists but nobody
knew right you know it we pretended you
guys want to stop pretending it doesn't
work that way you have to pretend we're
not fascists for this to work we have to
say things like oh we won't ban
abortions we'll just throw it back to
the States you can't tell everybody that
you want a ban abortion because we'll
lose every damn election from here on
out you guys have lost the the whole
grift you know we did it look look what
we did with Jun with with
W look what we did with W I mean that
guy we were able to do whatever the hell
we wanted
and pretend we were saving America we
invaded an entire wrong country to save
America because we kept the LIE going if
you go this Direction with
Trump you're G to go down with him and
that's what she's doing here folks
Tony's your spot on man she is not an
asset she is not a friend you don't want
her in the Foxhole behind you no she's
not she's not an ally in this fight
because she's fighting against the truth
and it's she's trying to protect her
image from the truth and the truth is
what you just said she was in for Trump
until she couldn't be she was and and as
long if it would have worked if would
have worked she'd have went along with
it she'd have went along with it she'd
have been fine if he'd have been the
dictator L Cheney would be the third in
the house right now oh and she she she'd
be grabbling at the king's feet she'd be
gring at the [__] King's feet Texas
ball but she's not she's not because she
wasn't invited to the [__] party and
that's the point that's the whole point
is Liz Cheney's Liz Cheney's objective
wasn't democracy Liz Cheney objective
was to save the Republican Party her she
picked party over country folks and
she's not telling you that truth and
until she tells you that truth and she
gets with the truth she is no [__]
Ally to us and she is no weapon that we
can use against him because frankly it
will backfire on you when you use Liz
Cheney's lies to weaponize against the
[__] truth it's just not GNA work
it's like it's like you said Texas ball
and it's like Williams said she's she's
Mike Pence and address to think that
Mike Pence and his legal staff were
wasn't looking for any way they possibly
could find to capitulate to Donald Trump
you're being ridiculous to act like Mike
Pence was some kind of hero I listen to
the January 6 elect hearings I listen to
the [__] to to the vice president's
Le Council I listened to them tell
America in the January 6 hearings that
they were looking for any way any way
they could to make this work and they
couldn't find one because it wasn't real
it was all delusional it was all
[__] and that's why it backfired on
them and that's why it's backfiring on
him now and here's here's the other
thing I point I want to make because I
know people I know people don't like me
talking about Liz Cheney this way
because Liz chain is saying the [__]
they want to hear and and she's being
anti-trump and all this [__] and you
know all she's a great Ally and and I
and I know it feels like I'm fighting
against the fight but that I'm not I'm
not fighting against the fight I'm
fighting for the [__] truth here
because if we don't fight for the
[__] truth in 2024 crazy [__] can
happen crazy [__] can happen if we don't
fight for the truth and let me tell you
something what I really want is for this
narrative to leak out into the public
that Liz Cheney's little PR2 isn't
[__] working that the pro-democracy
Coalition doesn't believe her and she
ain't no [__] hero [__] her and her
book and if that word gets out to Liz
Cheney maybe Liz Cheney will do what I'm
saying and get on [__] TV and do a
[__] real interview and get with the
goddamn truth and as soon as she gets
with the truth then fine she can come to
this side and she can be an ally for
democracy but until she stops [__]
lying until she stops [__] misleading
the American people [__] her [__] her
[__]
her that's right go [__] yourself and if
you think that I'm going to stand back
here and let her do the [__] you pay me
for my book and profit off the demise of
our democracy that she is responsible
for and not take responsibility well
[__] you too I'm not gonna do it I'm not
GNA sit here and shill for Liz Cheney
because she's saying [__] that I want to
hear [__] that [__] ain't gonna happen
she's [__] lying she's lying to you
sorry Texas no don't be sorry [__] man
Amen brother I was about to throw a
Hallelujah out there um I'm telling you
maybe we need may maybe we need a
Hallelujah and an amen button rat [__]
you think about this from think about
this from a strategic point of view
let's say you do you know they're saying
well let's use her okay fine you partner
up with Liz Cheney she's now the
Republican party's
enemy the first thing they're going to
do is they're going to say you idiot she
was in the
room I can tell you she was a
participant that's right then what now
you're now you're an insurrectionist now
you're now yeah now you're with the coup
plotters so what are you gonna do now
you're now you're in bed with until she
repents until she tells the [__]
truth to us I don't want to hear [__]
from LZ Cheney it ain't it ain't more
than this guy saying this [__] right
here listen to this [__] bogus criminal
cases trying to put their leading
political rival me in prison let's put
him in prison he's leading by a lot
there's no way we can beat him let's put
him in prison they're running police
state operations to infiltrate the
Catholic Church as if it were a
communist country they're persecuting
Christians and pro-life activists
they're persecuting anybody they want to
persecute they've labeled ordinary
Republicans and parents at Schoolboard
meetings as potential domestic
terrorists they're resettling millions
of migrants into our community
destroying our country like it's never
been destroyed before they're calling
our citizens criminals they Rigg the
last election they rigged the Democrat
primary and they're trying to get their
Rivals thrown off the ballot everywhere
they can and they're constantly trying
to delegitimize the Supreme Court of the
United States and threatening
conservative judges with violence in
short nothing about crooked Joe Biden
and the anti-democratic party has
anything to do with defending democracy
so if crooked Joe wants to turn this
election into a question of which
candidate will defend our democracy and
freedom then I say bring it on oh it's
on [__] it's [__] on [__] it's
[__] on challenge [__] accepted
because it ain't Joe Biden that's
fighting you you stupid bastard it ain't
Joe Biden it's the pro-democracy
Coalition it's people out there that do
[__] believe in democracy that do
[__] believe in Liberty real [__]
Liberty not this fake patriotism [__]
these [__] fake Patriots out there so
bring it on [__] it's already been
brought [__] we've been bringing it we
want in [__] we W in Ohio we want in
[__] Virginia we won in Kentucky we
stopped your stupid little lie of a
[__] Red Wave we won back we won back
more of the Senate it's been brought
[__] we've won every single [__]
referendum in states that protected
women's rights in the way of women's
rights every [__] last one of them
[__] it is on we are bringing it
we've been bringing it so so strap in
[__] because the fact of the matter is
Texas Paul that Liz Cheney caused this
situation she helped cause this
situation and she knew that this guy was
a [__]
buffoon before we
did she knew it tell I can I could do a
whole goddamn show on that part of my
language sorry I could do a whole show
on that one clip right there just going
point to point to point to point to
point to point you know play a section
stop address what he said play a section
stop address what he said I mean all of
it I mean just just talking about
they've tried to run candidates against
Joe Biden and he can't help himself that
you know the truth is the hardest thing
to keep in your mouth in in interviews
with criminals it's common for them to
cover their
mouth trying to keep that truth in
trying to keep it in in an interview and
that's what he's doing right there he's
outing himself with everything he says
oh they're fixing the primaries that's
him whining because Robert Kennedy Jr
didn't take off that was their plan
Steve bennon the human scab ran RFK Jr
he was supposed to sink Joe Biden didn't
work now they're funding Joe
mansion that [__] that [__] the better
didn't yeah over and over and over again
that's what that comment was about then
you can talk about the the Supreme Court
Justices he knows they're screwed
they've been bribing those people for
freaking decades and he knows they're
screwed people are going to be watching
that under a microscope forever from now
on this is this is not going back to
business as un as usual I guarantee you
the next freaking trip that that
Clarence Thomas takes there's going to
be reporter waiting there with a
microphone Mr Thomas who paid for this
trip you know I mean they're whining
about everything that they've been
getting caught at over and over and over
again just just listen to him every
point is something that's happened to
him you know that they're they're the
the whole part about they're going after
their political enemies you weren't even
a political opponent when this
investigation
started you weren't running for [__] you
ran to try to save your
ass you you know you weren't even a
candidate for a party when they when
they filed charges against you brother
so no none of this flies I could do a
whole show on that one little clip man
well you got I I'll I'll send you the
clip and you can do it on your show
tomorrow um here's here's what I want to
say about this clip here's what I'll say
about
it I'm very confident that we're going
to beat this [__] very confident
I honestly I want this [__] little
[__] this whiny little [__] this
attention [__] to be their nominee I
want it I want to bring it I want I want
this country to dunk this [__]
in the trash bin of History again and I
hope he comes back in 2028 and we do it
to him [__] again [__] this guy [__]
the Republicans I want to prove to this
country and the world that this party is
dead and it's dead because of him and
not only because of him but because they
capitulated to his dumbass and they
handed over their Republican cult to him
the cult leader that's what they did
they've been looking for a cult leader
for a long time Texas Paul and honestly
I can't tell you more how how more
excited I am that Donald Trump's entire
platform is Revenge and retribution and
that this country is going to buy that
[__] as some sort of policy that
this country's gonna feel sorry sorry
for this spoon silver spoonfed
[__] this spoiled little [__]
this whiny little [__] baby that
they're going to feel sorry for this
[__] there is 81 million people
that voted against Donald Trump in this
country in 2020 and those 81 million
people still exist and it's building
that Coalition is building and building
and building and the more this
[__] whines and the more he
talks about retribution and the more he
[__] gets his his mind comp book out
and parrots that [__] with the Vermin
talk and the blood poisoning his [__]
racism and his fascism bring it on [__]
bring it on oh it's been botten that's
right [__] it has already been
brought and I'm telling you I'm telling
you you must engage in your democracy
you must not get [__] distracted by
these shiny little objects like a story
about Liz Cheney telling lies to us how
she wasn't involved in this [__] because
that's a [__] lie getting distracted
by every single little motion that comes
out of every single criminal court or
civil court case of Donald Trump getting
distracted by 14th Amendment talk that
ain't gonna happen it's going to go to
Supreme Court and they are gonna squash
that [__] you dumb [__] it
ain't gonna happen stop getting
distracted stay focused stay focused on
winning and where you win how you win
and who the [__] you win against we've
been doing it and we should keep doing
it and that is what we do we engage in
our democracy as a [__] Coalition
because there's one goddamn thing they
can't stop there's one goddamn thing
they can't stop oh they can they can
they can hide the faces on the January 6
select committee they they have
chairmanships in the house they can lie
their asses off about truck payments of
Hunter Biden they can they can continue
on and on and on with their Hunter
derangement
and try to convince them but there's one
thing they can't stop and that's this
Pro democracy Coalition making sure to
defend democracy with our ballot and
that is the weapon we use not Liz Cheney
not some false [__] narrative not
some lies that Liz Chene is telling we
use our ballot and we use the engagement
in our ballot to win this the other
thing that you can do Texas Paul is come
here every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours Tuesday it's Texas
Paul Tuesday it's Texas Paul thunderbutt
Tuesday as far as I'm
concerned Boom the Texas Paul Sonic Boom
go to real texas.com if you want to hear
podcast with maybe room farts that pick
up on the microphone Maybe not maybe I'm
wrong maybe I'm crazy I just played the
tape that's all I did I just show it you
you decide Texas Paul I'm so glad that
you let me goof on you I I know you're a
good sport and I and I thought that was
I thought it was hilarious when it got
sent to me I'm so glad that you're such
a good sport and and I we love having
you here on Tuesdays so go to Real Texas
paul.com don't forget his show tomorrow
he's gonna be I'm sure he's gonna be
talking about Liz Cheney that interview
and maybe that video I just made of
Donald Trump the whiny little [__] D at
Marlo Mar Lago going on his retribution
to her and also make sure to tune in
here every single [__] day you go to
the Tony michaels.com make sure to
follow Gabe does not have a show today I
know a lot of people are going to be
disappointed hearing that but he does
not have a show today he's dealing with
his car issues he's got insurance stuff
that he's dealing with I'm hoping that
he gets his wheels back that's what I'm
hoping whether he gets a new car or you
know some other car I hope Gabe gets
that figured out so he won't have a show
today but tomorrow tomorrow we'll have
what was that live right after the with
Gabe Sanchez so go to real texas.com go
to IAB sanchez. follow Gabe there and go
to the Tony michaels.com make sure to
catch all the stuff Tony Michaels same
time same place
tomorrow you know the drill you know the
[__] drill Sur up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at@ the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
[Music]
holy [__]
[__] get the [__] out of
here
[Music]
oh holy [__] [__]
get the [__] out of
here
[Music]
oh holy [__]
[__]